citizens of the reject Nation it is time to
complete another continuity you thought after
dcam you would be a long time till we finish
something up but nay there's a sequel to A
movie we watched two movies ago we are about
to watch Justice League Doom which is part
two to Justice League crisis on Two Earths
so we got some sets of sequels going on I've
never seen it John's never seen it never seen
it very excited about it you know how this
works you leave a like you leave a comment
you hit that chair you tell your friends and
family you love and care about them because
it's important to do so as often as possible
because you never know when you're gonna die
and while we watch Justice League Doom you
know what you could wear a bet for a shirt
because you know who's in this the Batman
and the bad verse features three of the Batmans
none of the ones featured here unless there's
a big twist and I'm unprepared for a live-action
appearance of an actor in this animated film
but you can go to shop zero edition.com and
pick yourself up some bad first and you also
enjoy us watching this if you want to enjoy
us watching front to back start to finish
with some resting faces then you become a
super sexy reject over at patreon and enjoy
that whole shebang it is gonna be awesome
I am very excited we will see you soon let's
dive in to Justice League do foreign
crossover confusing everyone that's the other
Earth it's crisis in two words and then it's
them in the Marvel and you're like why are
we here what are we doing Justice League dude
I choose to accept this Mission Mr Hunt absolutely
and Kevin Conroy [Music] there he is Guy Gardner
himself Al Jordan I mean and the one casting
like ripped from so many of these animated
movies Carl lumbly hell yeah I love Carl Lumber
hey all right all right now Luther but it's
still good dude he's the Luthor I'll take
him as flash let's do this Justice League
Doom let's Doom this
yes this makes sense it's the emails from
Batman v Superman ah it all comes together
and all ties in
oh oh no should have driven there Batman
uh damn you Gambit told you Dr Doom Marvel
crossover this is Batman I found them and
tell cyborg he was right about how they've
been breaking into these places Hold Your
Position help is on the way yeah
whoa that's what I call a safe cracker
we don't want industrial Diamonds the boss
Listen To The King 10.
see you [Music]
[Music]
cute I can do this all day Oh Captain America
everybody take what you can and get out right
as soon as I kill Batman that's gonna happen
oh smart oh wait Batman came here alone I'm
supposed to be worried about Robin those sleeves
on my dude the shoulder pads are really doing
the work
oh yeah that's right crap it's the Justice
League [Music] that's their whole slogan crap
it's the Justice League add that Queen that
leaves Jack haven't seen him since he's sick
days on me it couldn't have gone far you search
the Vault I'll take the rest of the building
but where's the joke yeah not nice [Music]
gauntlets the only one able to cancel with
cards Wonder Woman I love that's how physics
works I love there she is flying card hoverboards
don't bother I just looked everywhere the
whole complex except for the last Vault room
shall we after you like you've got a choice
good job I thought he got shot in the face
first wow it's over
you're gaming
[Music] dang [Music] [Applause]
God though like the bend and stretch of this
animation is fascinating say good night Ace
surrender peacefully and you will not be harmed
really really don't sell Martian
oh trying to make me look away it's not gonna
work phase phase Berry
[Music]
clotheslined him anything on the hard drive
a lot I'm still sorting it all out
wake up King got some questions for you ah
wake up King I want a lawyer you're getting
ahead of yourself first you want a doctor
who gave you the technology that allows you
to walk through walls I do not know I know
you don't like to do it Sean not unnecessarily
I like it a lot in the right circumstance
I've read the minds of his entire group none
of them knows the origin of the device I'll
take these guys to booking and the rest of
you can sleep on what we've learned I don't
need to sleep I need to follow up Bruce a
session with my healing Ray could save you
several days of recovery time I'm fine Diana
I take him up on the that sounds great the
Ray would so much more productive you could
search the hard drive on the device for I've
still got 16 petabytes of data to sort through
I'll call you as soon as I've got something
that answers wants to work it's a workaholic
this guy let him rest okay it's gonna go home
and rearrange the bat cave now
interesting Batman loses Nation not going
to let me go to work not until you've had
proper medical attention Fine Food and a minimum
of eight hours bed rest let's just get this
over with I made chicken soup you can eat
while you brewed and I'll put in your stitches
Alfred is rye but I like them it's like more
Rye than you yeah a little extra like oh I'm
not gonna deal with your [__] Batman I've
dealt with this for so many years this is
the most entire plan
see-through guy you sure this thing will work
the amount of money I paid lexcorp get it
better the information I sent you to steal
is far more valuable than Batman's secret
identity High sides I already know it oh who
would Lex Corp and hmm it's got to be Doctor
Doom gotta be Doctor Doom only man of mine
now
skinny Bane yeah right it was a skinny Luchador
sveltebane ah yes of course nobody's shaming
deadbeat
whoa Star Sapphire Spain isn't it I'm a taller
scary guys and the lady with a claws is cheetah
some kind of suicide
what is happening Doom welcome to the hall
of Doom I'm Vandal Savage this guy's back
you each have a personal Vendetta against
a member of the Justice League I have a vision
for this world and they would stand in my
way their deaths would serve my goals and
any of you who would like to continue working
with me are welcome to share in the reaches
I don't see any of us looking for the exit
welcome to the Legion of Doom Legion of Doom
let's go better live up to that name I have
some unpleasant news but no how could this
have happened where are my parents caskets
dark um you found it like this just a few
minutes ago no I called the house right away
whoever did this is going to pay perhaps I
can help you with that yeah I may have been
lying what
about right give me my boy I think maybe we
actually surprised you I forgotten it was
my birthday also I'd never mentioned it to
any of you your stalker knows all did you
call him John is that John Aarons I think
so oh John Henry I didn't order that it's
from the lady damn it do you know her I do
not I will no she just got you a cake you
seem very familiar I can't place your face
that's unusual for me really look
oh it's Jon Jones oh that makes sense
[Music] yeah
what do you want cheetah to hurt you Diana
what else Ah that's my whole purpose in these
Comics I have one goal every time oh cool
sweet
hey can we wrap this up we're blocking traffic
and it's obvious what happened is it it's
just that the facts don't fit the scenario
don't investigate the crime scene again this
guy's dead and I'm alive alright mirror Masters
robbing the new maglev train from Keystone
City bag and tag everything and be thorough
this is a murder not an accident where you
going train station he's got a very subtle
secret identity what's that ring on your hand
yeah you big flash fan I guess weird I've
never seen him in the same place yeah oh hey
they actually did it yeah I mean that Ring's
not gonna you itself they call themselves
The identity Brotherhood they plan to use
the salt mine as their base during the second
American Revolution which is they claim imminent
it killed a dozen people and wounded three
of my men and seasoned so many meals so many
not gonna make a Green Lantern you're in a
cake I know it was a perfect opportunity
flashlight but you're in a cave Lantern it
up I know it's what you charged in but it'll
always be great the little iconography yeah
come on how often do you get the lantern took
you long enough to get here I brought you
something
hologram figures which one of us is real I
don't care punch them all
oh dude sometimes you gotta have your parents
Graves thrown at you in there you know grave
yep really get close to their memory what
we fought before I broke the bat today I break
the man [Music] your spirit or your body the
whole man
she's still alive
don't move at the end of the countdown already
in progress the Box will activate and instantly
kill the old woman it's a trap most probably
but you can't take that chance are you fast
enough Flash [Music] oh right through the
wrist if you try to remove the bomb it explodes
if you do nothing in 60 seconds it explodes
once you start running if you decelerate it
explodes speed it's laced with a chemical
that has an odd effect on Martian biology
you couldn't taste it over the soda damn it
your body will filter about in a few hours
[Music] don't you matter can't hold your liquor
stay back damn it you must get everyone away
from me you're all in grave danger oh no no
please stop drop and roll partner hang in
there look at this where's bibo at that's
not I thought it was bar but I don't think
it is that's fine because I thought that was
stealing there for would be yeah Billow and
Superman's Metropolis but it wasn't can you
see him Jimmy wow I think that guy works for
our paper good touch with the yeah shaky lens
vision
that's poor enough Lantern you make a move
and that drill is coming down on their heads
step away from the control panel and you won't
get hurt there's no other way out of this
yeah try me
the shutoff is controlled from one of the
other consoles in this mine this is like a
maddening video game it really is yeah
catch them catch the debris the old anti-drill
drill trick eh that bracelet trick always
impresses me at least I got to you once [Music]
up poisoned I can't thank himself drugged
me catch me if you can
it's not bad
oh damn it it's not possible mirror Master
trick but drugs closer I'll do it redundancy
plan follow the light it's a safe path back
to the surface they've still got Carol from
bookkeeping they took her hostage first make
him a lantern it would help see in the dark
in a cave it's a tool I'd use yeah it's Gotta
cast more spread than the string yeah let's
go
all your partners are captured or worse you've
got no options I've got one oh
oh damn bad
I don't understand why didn't I disarm him
oh no yep oh this is bad man they got you
all between a rock and a hard place she sort
of looks like me doesn't she what her name
was Carol too she's beautiful of course and
she has dark hair like mine and the stench
of your failure hanging over her I'm afraid
afraid that you don't deserve to have so much
power that nobody does no one man should have
all that power I hope you have the decency
to do what's right and suffer for your many
sins a secret cat always suffering [Music]
damn I don't think I've ever seen how that
emotional they've all got the exact thing
against them that they know would break them
newspapers are dying I spent my life fighting
for the little guy fighting for truth and
Justice in the American way
[Music]
oh no
range
of course Kryptonite heart
[Music] the disguises Legion of Doom started
out so fun and now I'm starting to feel increases
ominous yeah start off all bouncy like a like
a Justice League episode yeah like oh this
is a fun time no no Jon Jones Is On Fire
flash that's right God
bless the bottom of his hand wow you were
concerned about where I put your parents they're
very close
rest in peace wow
so cruel yes that thing doesn't have any repressed
Rage or problems with his parents get your
uh Kill Bill on you know
the next stage of my plans might be considered
genocidal oh good destroy the world nothing's
so crude half two-thirds at the most Thanos
Savage yeah even harder that I am old older
than the human race 80 000 years ago oh yeah
one night the sky lit up with streaks of fire
meteors but my primitive mind thought the
stars were falling from the sky oh yeah one
meteor fell to Earth in my Valley I slept
there bathed in the meteor of strange radiations
and when I awoke the next morning I was forever
changed the radiation mutated me evolving
me I was instantly aware of my increased intelligence
again the intellect of a modern human working
smart now guys yeah I cannot die is that a
fact go ahead foreign
but I would so love it if you just like that's
the end of the movie credits you know he talked
to big girl game in his new world our money
doesn't matter it's a good point you guys
are all there for that you are interested
money won't matter it's trivial in the long
run
and I tried to kill you 75 000 years ago a
disaster newly rendered Humanity extinct I
Enslaved the survivors and ruled with an iron
hand guys I did Pompeii I did my people were
well underway to repopulating the Earth and
becoming the planet's dominant species tell
them how to dance and how to lift those who
survive will happily follow a leader who offers
food comfort and order to you my Warlords
I offer dominion over as much of what remains
of the planet as each of you can hold that's
a loaded promise how do you propose to kill
that many people even without the Justice
League they will fight they hmm yeah I'm counting
on them fighting
I have one large missile this missile is Big
we're okay it's a specialness [Music]
why did you rob that grave that's what it
should have been damn good it's good work
yep so let's pretend I said it a few scenes
ago yeah something at it it's there
take out all the civilians you think are her
why are you guys attacking Wonder Woman she
was fighting the cheetah then suddenly started
attacking everyone we got the civilians out
and the park sealed off but we can't get anywhere
near her look at her she's having a seizure
or something no uh I'm gonna talk her down
pull your men back I feel like cyborg is the
only one who hasn't been like directly challenged
yeah I wonder if he has got like a virus and
it's gonna activate or or if he will be the
key or if they didn't know about him because
he didn't seem like he was always around whatever
that weapon is cheetah it won't work it's
a scanner something's happening to you did
you just call me cheetah no uh she thinks
I'm cheetah
they're broadcasting directly into your Visual
and auditory centers making you see whatever
cheetah wants you to I've identified the frequency
so I'm just gonna broadcast
no [Music] like who talks like that likes
me to do this cheetah I don't know does it
make sense it's a rough situation I get why
she wouldn't believe it but also
yes
[Music] hey cyborg you know with the one arm
you're ripped off as thus far resisted all
attempts to cut flash I need you to go to
Star Labs Kyoto and have them Forge a piece
of kryptonite into a scalpel bring it to you
can't help you we got a bomb bolted to my
wrist if I stop it'll explode I've seen speed
as well
need your help
I'm on fire right now yes I've seen Carrie
as well yes I'll forget the bad Wing ready
the Justice League is under attack by whom
fine bites oh it's the things he devised to
take them out and Vandal Savage found it so
he knows how to kill them all and he knows
there's been his weaknesses his family and
he put him in the dick damn it come on Batman
I'm with cyborg bring him with you the plans
don't account for him he could be the king
oh yeah see there you go how far away are
you from an iceberg I'm never far from anything
you think that'll slow it down enough just
to make one misstep got it at least if it
doesn't work nobody dies with me and the ozone
it's not polar bears drinking their Coca-Cola
[Music]
cheese poor guy
[Music] nicely done nicely done flag damn
could be worse could be worse we can still
save Superman and Green Lantern if you do
exactly what I say got a contingency fan for
my anti-justice league contingency plan that's
how deep Batman's lair goes man but what if
the contingency plan on the Batman contingency
plan doesn't do the Justice League intention
Supply we need to access contingency plans
sub level 108. call Batman Beyond it's harmless
to my Martian physiology but ideal for neutralizing
the Magnesium I was secreting how did he know
right now you have to prep for surgery surgery
great comic where Batman made a robot that
could take out all the Justice League and
him if he ever lost his mind so Batman has
to fight this robot that's the antithesis
of all of Batman smarts such a good run I
was the one whose arrogance led to this girl's
death I know more than a little about arrogance
I also know about dead bodies and that isn't
one oh oh dang you were dosed with a synthesized
version of the scarecrow's fear gas because
will is the source of your strength and fear
is the enemy fear is the mind killer it's
true a piece of kryptonite that you're going
to use like a lens narrow your blaster to
minimum and filter it through yes laser surgery
that's good woof
oh that looks painful pay a lot of money on
that in certain uh internet circles
[Music] big blue he's in hologram form so
whoever set them up with that interdimensional
lock pick also gave mirror Master the means
encrypted files from the back computer when
my files are decrypted they call home Louisiana
swampland oh The Big Easy land of Doom fly
into the sun trailing magnetic resonance it
will trigger a solar flare that will propagate
at light speed along the magnetic Trail we've
left and eight and a half minutes later utterly
destroy the sunward-facing side of the earth
wow and thanks to the accompanying electromagnetic
pulse any technology more advanced than say
the steam engine will simply stop working
that's quite an ambitious plan
he should have been burning for weeks actually
none of you managed to finish the job did
you get all that
[Music]
only fight your own villains not other people
you could take out more easily yes now they're
too much crossover Come On Let's cross over
it's the climax
[Music]
yeah I mean yeah go tick on cheetah or something
you'll be defined I still can't believe what
you tried to do to me you hurt me Jordan you
broke my heart and I'll never stop trying
to hurt you back gotta let go of them grudges
man [Music] oh it's like an anime now it's
all tentacles
that's new I do love mirror man's like translucent
look yeah it's pretty cool [Music]
yes tail truly the Cape of the animal kingdom
[Music] cool
star oh he's here [Music]
oh
[Applause] [Music]
where's the flipping countdown command come
on missile launch aborted no [Music]
foreign [Music] devil always knows the wick
you never asked me how my wrist was healing
hmm fine how's your
manual launch sequence engaged
yes beat that crane game cyborg
[Music]
always looks so painful
yeah I've never seen it red before [Music]
as a badass kick yeah all right Batman I'll
stop a rocket yeah grab on to it it's on you
what's Superman doing is he still fighting
Metallo
foreign
[Music] [Laughter]
[Music] [Applause] that was really cool with
the cat's cradle yeah [Music] hey
[Music] I do keep hurting you don't I Savage
launched the weapon Superman's already in
Pursuit on it it still seem like a job maybe
for the two here
oh no [Music] let's go soups
he's so charged up
thank you
no
stop the magnetic Trail or whatever love that
magnetic Trail by the way blow some ice breath
on it or something the solar flare is coming
out how to stop it oh no but we've got less
than eight minutes to figure something out
Batman maybe longer oh what do you got [Music]
I know how they intended to survive the intangibility
techie gave the royal flush game it must have
been a test run sure the Hall of Doom is the
apparatus can this building generate a signal
strong enough to make the whole earth intangible
if we had enough power also it would help
if it were higher up I can help you out with
that yes now you're working like a team thank
you
[Music] the displacement field ready I think
so I'd like to test this is the test this
is the test roll on rehearsal gang get in
one
come out
damn
is at the same place it was a seafood place
a seafood place not paper it was the other
one still no demo is he okay
it's a very cool visual [Music] oh hey leave
a like the world court has just found Vandal
Savage guilty of crimes against humanity tell
them what the immortal God life in prison
he is I want to officially welcome the newest
member of the Justice League by unanimous
consent cyborg welcome all done Bud now Batman
knows how to kill you yep that's how you get
in it's your welcome package we have to decide
whether Batman should be allowed to remain
in the league before we vote I think the accused
should be allowed a few words in his defense
my actions don't require any defense in the
same situation I do it again huh man if you
people can't see the potential danger of an
out-of-control Justice League I don't need
to wait for a vote especially after what we
dealt with like with the crime assist crime
League or whatever they're called crime syndicate
my contingencies were intended to immobilize
not kill but Savage came up with a plan to
bury you I assume so it wasn't one of mine
my plan for me is way better I would have
done this you're still so arrogant you didn't
bother to come up with a plan to stop yourself
I do have a plan it's called The Justice League
just wanted to be sure I don't have any innate
super abilities you guys should be able to
take care of me pretty easily I'm just a guy
I'm a guy in a suit a bad suit I want there
to be somebody I can trust to keep the planet
safe even from me wow wow that is Trust
oh hey oh I didn't realize it was that I knew
we'd pass but I didn't think it was like 2011.
wow
holy that was great that was a lot of fun
oh very much enjoyed that oh Dennis off was
mirror Maps yeah that makes sense that's a
very unique voice and Bruce Tim was Ace how
that went down a little bit a little bit at
the top there I thought it was Ace the bat
Hound I was like I was like Ace was in and
spoke also was like was there a barking in
the in the back yeah yeah the Royal flesh
they were like Jack queen king Ace yeah look
at this
look at them it's like the George Clooney
South Park camp yeah or whatever that is what
just happened oh that's so funny I left uh
that was fun yeah I liked two Arts a bit more
uh yeah sure but this uh this was really cool
to like have some of the OG voice actors back
the ones that like we really like in these
roles like Rosenbaum and obviously the one
and only Batman of Animation there are many
many other great Batman but like there's no
one quite like Kevin Conroy um and Nathan
Fillion such a such a formative Green Lantern
and uh Susan Eisenberg was the the name I
remember from the other one Roman she's great
it's such a clear like crisp voice but yeah
this was um the voice acting is fantastic
I honestly think the voice acting was a little
bit stronger in the animation uh do you feel
like the animation was a little on the on
the underfunded side at points uh there were
some times that like the physics didn't seem
to follow its own rules or like certain positioning
and like you know there were there were elements
that felt like it was a little uh lower budget
but the writing was so good and the and the
acting was so good I was able to like kind
of re-engage um but yeah I really enjoyed
this I love the story of of you know Batman's
fail-save comic which I referenced a little
ago um it was not long ago it was actually
the current run of Batman by chipset RC is
only on issue like 13 that was issues one
through six this is only like a one-year-old
comic like this is a new run and it's called
Fail-Safe and it's the idea that Batman has
those contingencies for everything else and
the Fail-Safe for him is this robot that can
defeat him and all of them so I've always
loved the idea that Batman I mean we've referenced
it like Batman out thinking everyone like
3D chess so many moves ahead yeah totally
and uh and this was a really cool use of that
story I really enjoyed this yeah I did too
this this was one that was interesting because
this started out in a way where I was like
okay this is going to be a little lighter
a little bit more just like ah you know is
it kind of a fun outing it felt more like
oh we're watching like the animated series
or something right now and then as it went
and as it really picked up steam and as you
really got to understand what the master plan
was with Vandal Savage and the uh the leak
of Doom and all that stuff like I it started
to sing and it started to kind of rise to
that level of you know what you'd expect out
of a crisis on Two like crisis on Two Earths
is such like a it feels like such a crisp
sort of event movie yeah sort of have a direct
sequel I think at first I was a little taken
aback I was like okay this feels like just
kind of another adventure and it sort of ties
in because they have this interdimensional
you know Tech involved but yeah like as it
slowly started to be revealed that like oh
okay this is the master plan is to yeah use
Batman's contingencies and warp them so that
they are death plans instead of just neutralization
plans and watching as each member of the Justice
League is you know brought to their knees
and is is overcome and is you know met with
their you know deepest vulnerabilities like
yeah it just this was like a grower it really
started to hum and sing and yeah it's like
the crisis on tours I definitely remember
sitting there going like wow man just some
of these animation flourishes and some of
this yeah yeah it's like this one has a little
there were a couple moments where I'd find
myself noticing like oh wow what a what a
smooth you know motion shot or or what an
interesting little like you know yeah Bend
and squash kind of flourish or something but
it does overall feel yeah a little bit more
downgraded on that sense not just slightly
like there are a lot of still really lovely
designs and things like that but maybe not
as like visually striking as some of them
have been although I still appreciate you
know this era as opposed to like the dcamu
which is much more modern like I still styled
the classic animation I want to look at one
thing real quick to make sure that I have
the right name um but yeah I agree with what
you're saying and I and I do think like the
moment we were both struck by the animation
when like the planet and everything else we
definitely were both like whoa that's really
cool so there were definitely moments of flourish
and moments that like really sang that made
it at work um but at the same time I I did
notice that I was distracted by something
animation at points uh yeah that's fair that's
absolutely fair I'm ninety percent sure ninety
five percent sure yes uh Dwayne McDuffie invented
static shock okay cool cool so uh he also
did Ben 10 which is what I was trying to check
on so uh I knew the static shock but I didn't
want to be wrong about Ben 10 because that's
something I like I I love Ben 10 because nobody
Yuri voiced him um but Justice League Unlimited
Ben 10 as well as uh as the great static shock
we're doing McDuffie so I actually knew him
from static and uh then he's a fantastic comic
book writer as well but yeah so it's a it's
a bummer to I I didn't realize he'd been passed
for 12 years that's that's pretty crazy but
I love that they gave this you know a little
love to him as the writer of this and this
definitely felt like a classic DC experience
and adventure and like this felt like that
kind of like classic animated romp and experience
so yeah I mean it was a lot of fun but I definitely
I think we've been uh I mean we've been living
in this animated world for like 20 of these
uh 25 almost so like when they're when they're
these cinematic Opus is like what we just
experienced when it goes down to a little
bit smaller budget you notice yeah and I mean
this was one where I thought it kind of wrote
a line where I was you know some of them you're
like wow how did they manage to fit all this
into an hour and 10 minutes or whatever and
this was one where yeah I'm like this is this
all yeah it didn't feel too slight for what
it is but it didn't feel like oh wow how'd
you manage you know and and I think that the
for again the from my experience that that
grower quality that sort of like it picks
up momentum it picks up steam it gets better
as it goes I think kind of helps that to feel
sort of more natural rather than like ah like
a letdown or something like that um yeah it
feels like a little bit smaller a little more
contained The Master episode yeah exactly
it definitely feels like a big long episode
I wonder if it ever was because at one point
they like re-explained a moment like they
felt like a commercial break where they're
like Batman's the one that did it and then
they cut to them in the space thing they're
like and
they're like let's make it a movie yeah maybe
and maybe they aired this like split apart
right pieces and never had to like plan for
that or something which is also kind of a
fun feeling because I do like a nice Saturday
morning cartoon feeling yeah 100 no this is
it's a it's it's well at home within the Spectrum
I feel like and yeah it's like it reaches
a few Heights that do feel like that you know
sort of Hefty intensity that you expect out
of some of the biggest you know event stories
that we've seen thus far um and I thought
that like the most striking stuff he has like
Batman's contingency and the way that the
like the villains become more interesting
when you realize like oh they've stolen his
plan and are now going to wipe out half the
Earth it's like the the Vandal Savage stuff
you know I feel like he could be more of a
character yeah you know like all that I'm
a caveman yeah it's like I really liked watching
them fight and I really liked the pair offs
and and watching everyone struggle and then
overcome and come back together as a team
and really work as a team and and figuring
out how to stop the solar flare like that
stuff I I thought really started to rise to
that sort of harmonious level where you're
just not thinking about anything else yeah
so yeah it's like certain parts of this could
have been more developed but I feel like we've
seen stuff that's also less developed than
this sure um so yeah this was like this is
pretty decent and I liked yeah especially
just that hook of of what if Batman's contingency
plan fell into the wrong hands yeah the fact
that they at least talk about it afterwards
and this iteration the Justice League I think
is nice where you got a little bit more from
Martian Manhunter you got cyborg being inducted
here and I like that Dynamic too he's not
accounted for in this and that's part of the
key yeah but yeah yeah I agree I really enjoyed
that element and I love these casts uh relationships
I like their their familiarity with each other
this feels like the Justice League yeah so
yeah I had a great time uh this was really
fun if you guys have any others you want us
to check out we've been reading your comments
and seeing this was actually one of the ones
a lot of you recommended so we jump on into
it please let us know in the comments below
hit that like hit that notification Bell and
hit that share button because we want to keep
making these there are 50 some uh DC Animated
Universe films we're hitting that like 25
26 for somewhere in that range so we want
to keep cranking through them so let us know
what you want us to check out next before
we leave we got a patron of the day shout
out who we got who we got
Ricardo Martinez Bane was in this movie yeah
Bane was in this movie and I feel like he
is one of the very few I mean you got Blue
Beetle sure you got Bane how many more Hispanic
Heroes and Rogues are there Zorro that's the
only thing I got a problem with is the Blue
Beat of marketing they're like it's the first
uh Latin American superhero I'm like zoro's
the first superhero like like yeah yeah okay
inspired Batman okay so that's true right
but you know who inspired them all is freaking
Ricardo Martinez all right he's the original
he's the 00g that's right you're the archetype
for all formidable Latin characters absolutely
you were there at the beginning of time and
then you were bestowed this sort of magic
energy that unlocked all of your potential
and then everybody else in the world was like
we gotta cut it
thank you for enlightening us thank you for
blessing us with your prowess your knowledge
your Acumen and your formidable talents and
uh thank you for supporting us here at the
patreon appreciate you being here and uh yeah
stay pledged that's the ultimate plan no matter
how much of the Earth you might be wiping
out or who you might be attempting to save
I feel like the pledge I hope this building
is uh the the thing that transfers the power
through like we we're safe here with Ricardo
Martinez position of course if you wait to
the right time of day of course wait till
like the middle of the night okay like write
it like 10 p.m our time I think we should
be good we have enough time to kind of Outlast
the ray so Ricardo if you could arrange that
would very much appreciate if it's convenient
yeah all right that's going to do it to lovelies
we will see you next time for whatever's next
foreign [Music]